this is where we ended I think or for
noting that this should be n and not n
minus one but doesn't matter enjoyable I
wanted to show you the proof of the
theorem which not to get into but the
proof is not difficult there is only one
key word that I have to use okay talking
about lower band techniques improve
complexity so the keyboard is random
restriction okay this is a technique
which is used constantly in improved
complexity so that's one thing you use
in the proof but the idea is basically
that if you have a you want to show that
if you have short proof then you can
transform it into proof which is narrow
which doesn't contain any wide closes so
the problematic thing that can happen
that you have a short proof but there
are quite big clauses in it but clause
is a disjunction of variables now what
will happen if you pick a variable at
random and you fix it - I drew 0 at 1
and or 1 so if you have a big clause
that with a pretty decent probability
you will pick a variable from that
clause if now the variable appears
positively in the clause and you fix it
to 1 then the whole Clause becomes true
and it's completely useless in the proof
like a true clause which is evaluated to
constant 1 cannot be used in a
refutation so it disappears and that's
basically the idea and a little bit of
computations but random restriction
that's that's the key word and maybe I
shouldn't have called this lower bound
for resolution but lower bounds from
random restrictions
oh yes but I need to use the keyword so
now yes okay you have to do a little bit
more so of course what you want to do
like the after a restriction of course
it stays unsatisfiable because if you
restrict something unsatisfiable it
stays unsatisfied
what you should worry about more what
happens to the original clauses because
the restriction kills some clauses in
the proof but it will also be killing
the clauses in that you have started
with but the closest you have started
with are small and you massage it a
little bit and you have to apply the
restriction and then using the
restriction recover a refutation of the
original set of clauses not of the
restricted clauses so now I will move to
a different let's say proof technique
and that is by a reduction of proof
complexity lower bounds to communication
complexity so a communication complexity
I hope we'll be talking about but so if
what I say it doesn't make and a person
sense now it will make more sense after
a noob is talking but communication
complexity is a big field which talks
about complexity of communication and
now in this approach I would like to
reduce lower bounds on let's say
resolution or some other proof system to
non lower bounds from communication
complexity and the general strategy is
as follows so you will have a CNF and
you partition the variables of the CNF
into two disjoint sets and you consider
the following communication game so
Alice has a truth assignment to the
variables X 0 those are the variables
Alice sees Bob is an assignment to the
rest of the variables and since the
whole CNF is unsatisfiable
there must exist a clause which is false
under this asana and the objective of
the game is to find such a clause so you
think of it as the original set of
clauses so every Clause is just the
disjunction of variables which means
that you can write a clause uniquely as
C 0 or C 1 where this is the part of the
clause which depends on the variables X
0 the art of the variables X 1 L is
completely knows this value of the
clause Bob knows completely this value
of the clause and they are supposed to
find a clause which is false put it
differently so the clauses look
so Ellis knows all of these all over the
sea zeroes and bobs all know some of the
sea walls and they're supposed to find
the claws which is false which is
basically the intersection between the
false clauses that Alice sees and the
false clauses that Bob sees and as the
communication game now I would like to
make a very simple observation that if
you have a tree like resolution
refutation of C of size s s is the
number of inferences then the
deterministic communication complexity
is at most log S meaning that Alice and
Bob can solve this game by exchanging at
most log s bits or in other words if you
manage to find a proven lower bound on
the communication complexity of the game
you get a lower bound on the size of the
proof emphasized that we are talking
about tree like roots here and this will
be so in all of this
and the proof is simple so here we have
your resolution proof which is real life
and it SS inferences and the proof is
known to both of the players ok the
proof exists both of the players know
what it is and they use this proof to
construct the protocol so this thing is
a tree which means that somewhere in the
tree there will be load such that the
size of this thing
is roughly the half of the size of the
whole tree meaning that the size of this
is somewhere between so this thing is
not too big and not too small which
means that the compliment here is also
not too big and not too small so now
what the players do is that they look at
the claws see sitting here and they
exchange one bit by or two to agree what
is the truth value of the cross under
the assignment so remember that what
they have is an assignment alpha and
beta plus C is just the union of
something such that the Alice knows the
value of this under her assignment and
Bob knows the value of debt under her
Simon so they can evaluate this by just
exchanging one bit of communication and
that tells them what is the value of
this clause now supposing the clause is
false
so it's false so they know that if they
look at this sub refutation this
refutation well at this point get to
this false clause so they look at this
tree and they continue in the same
fashion if this course is true they just
remove the tree this sub tree from the
proof and they zoom in on the rest of
the proof and continue in the same
fashion until at some point they must
reach one of the initial clauses and the
initial course will be false
and it's the truth so at every step they
exchanged one bit and they in roughly
log as steps they identified an original
cross which was for maybe one detail
about is proof it's quite tempting to
prove this thing in a like a different
way that you would start from the empty
clause the two players know that this
empty cross is false and now you know
that you have used it to resolve X and
not X depending on which player knows X
whether X is known by Alice or Bob they
would decide whether the predecessor is
false and they would move forward in the
upwards in the tree until they reach
across that's a way also to prove it but
it doesn't give the right answer because
then you would bound the communication
complexity by the depth of the tree and
not by the size of the tree and it can
happen that the tree may be very deep
and spawn okay you could do that so yes
so that's exactly ladies argument so of
course you could from the protocol from
the proof you could get a tree like
protocol which is small and then you
could bounce the protocol or you can
directly do this
a nice application which I will not give
a prove it at this point is the bit
pigeonhole principle again now remember
that the bit pigeonhole principle said
that there is a 2 n plus 1 by 2 and
matrix
so that order rows of the matrix are
distinct
now if you think about the communication
game you have to define how to partition
the variables so there is there is one
natural way how to partition the
variables and that is partition it in
this way
meaning that Ellis would know this part
of the matrix and the Bob would know
that a part of the matrix which
basically means that for every pigeon
Ellis knows so you split the pigeons you
split the pigeons into halves and Alice
knows exactly where her pigeon goes and
Bob knows exactly where his pigeon goes
and we are supposed to find a collision
between the pigeons but it's relatively
easy exercise that if you do it this way
the communication game will actually
have small communication complexity so
this is not a right partition the
partition that works in this case is
that you partition the variables like
this so you partition the bits of the
holes into two parts so no single player
has any information about where each
pigeon goes he knows only half of the
bits of each pigeon and in this case one
can prove if you partition the variables
in this way the resulting communication
game will require something like log of
M bits which then gives you two to the
square root of n lower bound for the
pigeonhole principle now I'm not going
to prove the lower bound on the
communication game it's just an
illustration how you can apply this
strategy to prove a lower bound one
thing to note of course is that the
lower bound we get here is weaker then
from the width size trade-off and also
again it works only for tree like proofs
so it's weaker in
both the parameters and what it's
actually proving and and the proof
system that is actually working with
there is a different application and
matching communication upper-bound might
be I don't know because if there if the
upper bound I stated is the correct one
then actually the trivial protocol would
I don't know it's unlikely unless it's
unless is the trivial protocol
here's a different example which I will
use later and it's a little bit more
well known and the creek versus coloring
so so let's have N squared vertices or n
choose two vertices which you think of
as representing the graph on n squared
very variables that you think of as
representing a graph on n vertices now
introduce one formula which says that
the you add extra variables and you say
that the variables represent a clique of
size K plus 1 in this graph you can
write this as a CNF of a small size by
let's say saying that here is your graph
G which this is and your additional
variables Y would say that there is an
injection from a set of size K to some
subset of G such that everything in this
subset is connected and you can write
this as a CNF of a small size
another thing is that you can also
express the fact that Z is a que
coloring of your graph in a similar way
so we'll have another formula which says
that the the graph G is K horrible which
would be a similar way out to write it I
hope it's clear that how to write such a
thing but hopefully it doesn't matter
very much okay the specific way how I
express the clique and coloring CNF is
not very important there is one little
detail that I'll mention later but the
only thing that that is enough how to
write it to know that having a clique is
an NP property and occurring sawsan and
P property hence you can write it as a
small CNF and you can write it as a nice
CNF if you want in this way
and the observation is that this CNF is
unsatisfiable okay so it's impossible to
have a graph which was k plus one clique
which is at the same time k color so
this is an unsatisfiable CNN
and I would like to show again using the
same argument that this particle CNF
requires a large resolution reputation
and the previous game sort of looks a
lot like the following game and that's
it
that's a Koch motivation style game for
which looks as follows you have two
players Alice as a graph with which is a
k plus one clique and Bob has a graph
which is K colorable which means that
there exist an edge in the graph that
Alice's in G which is not contained in
the graph H because otherwise G would be
a subset of H which is suppose
if you have a any graph G which is a k
plus one clique and a graph H which is K
horrible
there must be an edge in this graph
which is not in this graph and now the
objective of this game is to find an
edge which is in G fortunately if you
choose the parameter K way exactly like
squared of NRA then the communication
complexity of this game will be n to
some constant which follows from like
lower bounds for of raspberr up on
monotone circuits which or rather the
digression which gives explicitly lower
bounds for this game with little bit
better parameters and now this sort of
implies that the clique versus coloring
requires Cilic resolution refutation of
like exponential size
well this is a little bit cheating
because if you remember the clique
versus coloring I don't really know how
to partition the variables in an
intelligent way so that you can directly
apply this argument but there is a
little trick and the trick will be
useful later so here we have the CNF
which is the creek
boring
and now I would like to partition the
variables into two parts in such a way
that the resulting communication game
will boil down to this Scotch
matriculation style game so that I can
apply the theorem of res burro others
but as far as I see this is not possible
so instead one modifies it in the
following way so for every variable X
you introduce a copy of the variable and
you will consider the following CNF so
you another variable X some other
variables at X bar and then you will
introduce a condition which says X is at
most X bar by which I mean you introduce
all clauses which says that not X IJ or
X bar IJ
now this original thing was
unsatisfiable this is also unsatisfiable
because this is now saying something
slightly different the original
formulation sense that there is one
single graph which contains a cleat and
is any set of same time colorable now
I'm saying something slightly different
I'm saying there is a graph which is a
clique which is contained in a graph
which contain which is kaikora blue
which is contained in a graph which is K
color that's also unsatisfiable that's
one thing another thing is that actually
the original formulation can be obtained
from this formulation by resolving the
additional variables so one thing I
haven't told you about the clique which
is important that in the way how we
formulate the clique siene all the
variables X are actually monotone there
is no negation in front of the variables
X which is reasonable to expect because
if a graph has a creek then every bigger
graph also has a clique
now since all of those variables are
occur positively resolve them with the
variables that occur here and actually
obtain
the original thing I started with just
so I can obtain the original thing
by a short resolution proof which means
that if I managed to prove the lower
bound on this then I'm also proving a
lower bound on depth on the original
formulation okay and now look at this
CNN so I'm claiming that the
communication game if I if Alice knows
the variables X are Y and Bob knows the
variables X Z is at least as hard as the
touch medicine game over there why is it
so so suppose that Alice has a graph
with k plus 1 click so this is the graph
it has a k plus 1 click
so she fixes the assignment y so so that
this CNF is actually true okay similarly
for Bob he has a graph which is K
colorable at the graph X he fixes that
to be actually the coloring of the graph
which makes this CNF true and now they
are supposed to agree on a all of clause
in here which is false but it cannot be
the clause which is contained here so it
must be a clause which is contained
somewhere here that is in other words
they found some Clause of this form
which is false which means exactly the
day they found an edge which is
contained in G and not contained in H
so this gives a so this shows that the
complexity of this game is at least m2
some Epsilon thanks to that theorem from
elsewhere we know that this and we have
a lower bound on results
so far this was just a different way how
to prove lower bounds for tree like
resolution which we already know but
coming back to the original theorem
there is a very little actually about
the resolution crew system which we
actually used in the argument we used
only the fact that in every line of the
proof Alice and Bob can decide cheaply
what is the truth value of that given
line so as long as you have a proof
system with this feature that every line
in the proof can be cheaply agreed on
between Alice and Bob in this
communication game then you
automatically get a lower bound so one
illustration is cutting planes again
okay now remember that the cutting
planes were just linear inequalities the
lines were just linear inequalities now
if you split the variables into two
parts the left-hand side also splits
into two parts and Alice or Bob knows
the exactly the value of his half of the
linear function
unfortunately Alice and Bob cannot tell
each other the value of the function
that they see because it's some integer
we didn't expect we didn't impose any
bounds on what the integer might be so
they can't really transmit the integer
but let's say if I restrict myself to
cutting planes where the coefficients
are small so then the amount of
communication they need to agree on the
value of the Clause will also be small
and you get a lower bound for cutting
planes tree like cutting planes with
small coefficients
okay exactly the same argument and you
don't have to think about it in general
if you don't want to restrict the
coefficients to be small then instead he
would use randomized protocols and one
can show that you can use smaller and
demise protocol to for the two players
to agree whether the inequality holds or
not and then the rest of the argument
becomes the same this I think is again
the result of Russell did this also kind
of shows one nice thing about this
generic approach is that to get this
lower bound on cutting plants you
actually don't need to know anything
about cutting planes if you remember
there was this there were three rules
some of them was like multiplication by
a constant heading rounding so in this
approach it doesn't matter at all what
rules you used the only thing used were
the properties of the lines and if you
decide to use some more complicated
rules the lower bound still holds the
only thing which matters in this
argument is was the communication
complexity of each individual line in
the proof not the complexity of the rule
its
let you speaker the world the public
doesn't game that is true or super
randomized oh yeah okay yes that's a
very good point sir yes this is I'm good
it's a very good point so then of course
I have changed the protocol into
randomized and I need some abandon
randomized protocols so the lower bound
of raspberr of an alum and bopanna is
for deterministic and it's actually
stronger lower bound which works for
monotone circuit but the lower bound for
as invigoration is actually for
randomized protocols so fortunately in
this case you have also have a lower
bound and randomized protocols
there's a different application and
which I found very nice and it's an
exponential rebound for tree-like degree
D cutting plans where you again
strengthen the communication models so
in the cutting planes case one
strengthen the communication model to be
moved from deterministic to randomized
but here one also allows like
multi-party communication degree D
cutting plans I will not exactly define
but you can think of it as cutting
planes where instead the inequalities
are degree D polynomials okay so let's
let's have the case that D is equal to
two so your lines would be any
expressions of this kind
those will be your lines and then you
would have some rules telling you what
to do with those lines and how to
combine them the point is that if you
split the variables into two parts and
the player is no longer can determine
whether this inequality is valid or not
because in this case every monomial
which was observed by at least one of
the two players whereas here there will
be some monomials which depend both on X
0 and on X 1 so the two players cannot
agree on the value of the inequality but
if you now split it split the variables
into three parts and use the number on
the forehead model then the players can
actually agree on the value of this
inequality plus some randomization so in
the degree tool cutting plane system you
would use multi-party communication
that's just to agree on this clause and
then there is this randomization which
is again just to handle the variance of
the coefficients but let's say if we
were modest and just we're wanted to
prove lower bounds for systems where the
coefficients are small it would be
enough to take randomized so here and
amassed a deterministic number on the
forehead protocols and the paper of beam
the pole and others it reduces the lower
bounds on this sort of system on
multi-party communication complexity of
disjointness now one thing I like about
this paper is that I'm not enough
essentially what the history was but the
paper reduced the lower bounds in proof
complexity to communication lower bounds
before the communication lower bounds
were actually known which sort of that's
true
which sort of justifies many of our
papers because you often reduce some
problem you cannot serve two apparently
even harder problem that you cannot
solve and it seems useless but here they
reduced a problem to a problem that
actually later has been solved which is
nice
so if you work just with bounded
coefficients then you don't need or
surely sorry
well there are several things okay so
one of them is to make this proposition
through okay so I want to have a
connection between size of a proof and
communication complexity so if the
coefficients are bounded then I don't
inter and the message I just need three
parties let's say it's one thing another
thing is how to actually prove this
result how to prove the reduction from
but a good communication complexity of
disjointness okay that's another thing
and that also uses randomization for
different reasons
so the randomization here is so even if
the coefficients are small to prove the
lower bound in this way you still need
to randomize
so is this so this is how to prove lower
bounds on she like proves it's a quite a
general technique which works sometimes
sometimes it doesn't work but it seems
that it essentially works only for
tree-like proofs it seems that this
cannot be extended in a reasonable way
to proofs which are non tree-like and
those two examples that I gave are just
several other examples where you can
actually prove the lower bounds in proof
complexity using this way which we don't
know how to prove in any other way
[Music]
well let's see that she like degree D
cutting plants
so let's stay on the safe side and say
that these fixed or damaged the question
so let's say if these fixed like a
thousand some Logan which I don't
remember
there is some loose
mm-hmm so now I will talk about
something which looks different but is
closely related and it's got feasible
interpolation which I think of basically
as what we just saw about communication
complexity but sort of just up so that
you can actually apply it to laundry
like proofs to general proofs to proofs
which are not just trees and I'm not
sure how apparent the connection will be
but let's let's see what's going on
so feasible interpolation the general
setup is the following so you again
prove allure bound and before we were
trying to reduce it the lower bound to a
lower bound in communication complexity
now I want to reduce it to a lower bound
in circuit complexity so you have a
proof system and a proof of some
tautology and you will show that if
there is a proof in your proof system
then you can solve some related
computational tasks relatively cheaply
and then prove a lower bound in
computational complexity to get a proof
complexity robot
and the way how people usually make it
work is the following so in the
communication game we had before there
were two sets of variables and two
players here for some reason there will
be three sets of variables XY and Z and
you will have an unsatisfiable formula
of the form XY and b XZ meaning that the
formulas a and b share only the
variables x and they don't share the
variables Y or Z actually the situation
we already discussed like in the Creek
and coloring so we had a clique which
says which says that the graph
represented by X has a creek and chorong
which says that a graph represented by X
has
dawai but the rove the wife was mainly
to shrink the formula okay so I cannot
say if I want to say that the graph has
a creek as a CNF I cannot do that so
that the CNF is short okay
I can't even do that by an arbitrary
formula unless something very strange
happens so the role of the Y is to just
shrink the formula and to have something
which expresses that the graph is a
creek but expresses it in a succinct way
so the the size of this formula formula
is polynomial in the size of the graph
if I didn't have the Y then it would be
exponential growth to the wines in the
row of Z is also to just ashamed for why
is it we connect so why might give you
the peak
yes--why gives it a click so think of Y
as actually being the click okay and so
this says that Y is a clique in the
graph X and this says that Z is a
coloring of the graph X okay so it just
gives you the witness
now if a and B is unsatisfiable then
there exists a C such that the following
holds so a implies C and B implies not
see this is yes because if
because if you if you just I think a and
B as unsatisfiable CNF s if you look at
the set a which is the set of all X's
for which there exists Y such that ax y
holds and similarly for B is the set of
X's such that there exists is Z such
that B hos so then those two sets are
disjoint so enough to have C which is
some superset of a which doesn't contain
B okay such as C must always exist and
now the that's the important thing so C
doesn't depend on minds okay so so it
depends on a and B but it doesn't depend
on Y and C so one way how to define such
a C is that you would define that C of X
is true if and only if there exists Y
such that ax y holds okay so that's one
way how to define it and this C will
have this property so such as he exists
for trivial reasons but now I want to
ask what can we say about the complexity
of this C so I will call this C as an
inter plant of a and not B
and another subtle thing to notice is
that if a is monotone in X meaning that
the variables in a X in a appear only
positively then you can actually fix C
so that it is monotone in X and now I
would like to ask what is the connection
between the length of a proof of a or
refutation of a and B and the
interpolant C of a and not B that's the
general strategy of the interpolation
technique so I will show you again the
Kliq versus coloring formula because I
find this sometimes a little bit
confusing what the interplant actually
does but in the creek in the clique
versus coloring example this is sort of
clear what the interpolant should be so
we have the clique and the coloring
again so why is a clique in the graph
represented by X Z is a coloring in the
graph represented by X the following CNF
is unsatisfiable and the interplant what
it does is the following so if you have
a graph which has escaped less 1
colorable then the interplant must
accept the graph if you have a graph
which has a horrible clique
it is a k+ one click then the interplant
should accept it if it is a colorable
the interpol should reject it so in this
way the interpolant distinguishes
between graphs which are capable on
coral coral treble and graphs which have
kept us on click and graphs which are K
quorum so it distinguish the two it
accepts on the ones with click and
rejects on the ones with our colorable
and on the are graphs it can do whatever
you want this is the on ik constraint
that I know about the Interpol
it's just distinguish between
distinguishes between the two
and here's the like the simplest form of
the interpolation theorem which is due
to krycek which shows that if a and B
has a resolution refutation of size s
furthermore assume that a is monotone in
X X then a and B have monotone in their
opponent of monotone script size roughly
s so in other words it tells you that if
a and B has a short refutation then
there will be a small monotone in the
rapport between a and not B
so I will not prove this but I might
give you a sketch
well so let's forget that the theorem is
actually true even without the word
monotone so if a is not monotone in X
you still get an interplant which will
be just a circuit the reason why krycek
states it in the monotone form is of
course that we can prove lower bounds
for mountain circuits and we cannot
prove romance for general circuits so
this is why the word monotone is there
but if you want to prove it without the
word monotone then the proof is fairly
straightforward so you have your CNF X Y
and basically the interpolant should
tell you which of the two if you fix an
assignment for the variables X so assume
that you fixed the assignment then what
you are getting is two C n FS which
don't share common variables okay so if
you fix X those two things don't share
any variables which means that at least
one of them is unsatisfiable on its own
okay there is no connection between the
two so ideally this answer this fiber or
this is unsatisfied and the inter plant
is trying to tell you given X it's
trying to decide whether this is
unsatisfiable or this is unsatisfied
that's what see does now assume that you
have a resolution refutation of this
thing so you fix an assignment for X you
feed it into this and into the
resolution Fe - what will happen is that
you are refuting two disjoint sets two
sets of causes which have disjoint sets
of variables now it's easy to show that
in a resolution refutation that means
that the refutation already contains a
refutation of either this part or of
this part there is a little snack which
I will not go into it's a detail but the
point is that if you have a resolution
refutation of two things with disjoint
sets of variables then at least one of
those things were already then the
refutation will already contain a
refutation of one of the two things but
everything I just told you can be done
in polynomial time so I will just take
my assignment to the common variables X
feed it into my resolution refutation
massage the resolution refutation and
get out of it a refutation of either
this or or or that which gives me a
polynomial size circuit which interprets
a and not B so that's
the sketch of the proof in the
nominative case in the monotone case the
proof is actually completely different
and much simpler and it shows that the
circuit is actually not o of s but s and
it turns out that the structure of this
circuit which interpolates the two is
the same structure like the graph of the
refutation and what you just do just
have your refutation and depending on
whether you are resolving on X or Y or Z
you just put there a little gadget into
the refutation that gives you a circuit
and that gives you and interpolant
here's the click and coloring again and
now I'm coming back again to the theorem
of rosboroughs
so if you fix a suitable K then every
moto in the operon interplant of click
and coloring requires a large circuit
size now by the result of krycek if you
have a short resolution refutation then
you have a small interplant
which automatically gives you a lower
bound on resolution recitations or this
particulate approach
given that I'm heading towards the end
so one point is that this corollary is
exactly the same thing we had in the
communication language okay but in the
communication language was it was the
same result except that we said she
liked resolution refutation so this
interpolation technique is at least in
this context is exactly the same thing
like the communication complexity except
you are getting better bounce
better bounce mean by proofs which are
not only trees and the way how to see
this we have to see this this connection
is that remember this Alice and Bob game
that you split the variables into two
parts and they are supposed to agree on
a falsified close so dead game after
like suitably changing the renaming the
variables is exactly the couch marvelous
in game four let's for a monotone
function which well it's actually
exactly the catchment of a glisten game
for the interplant C so the
communication game we saw before between
Alice and Bob corresponds to the Cartman
of innocent game of the interpol and
this way the difference between the she
like proofs and general proofs is
similar like the difference between
formal and lower bounds and circuit
levels so communication complexity
directly gives you lower bounds only on
formulas science whereas which gives you
lower bounds on tree-like truths
whereas in interpolation you are talking
about circuit size and that allows you
to talk about general long trailer truth
yes but yes well so I will give
is roughly the end I'll give just a
little bit more remarks about visible
interpolation so the connection with the
communication complexity was one the
second connection is that it also works
for stronger systems than resolution but
then you sometimes have to make the
computational model stronger so of
course you don't want to make the
computational models so strong that you
wouldn't be able to prove any lower
bounds but for cutting planes the
rubberband that I mentioned actually
proceeds by interpolation and but it's
not interpolation by monotone circuit by
monotone boolean circuit but it's an
interpolation by monotone real circuit
which is an object which is a little bit
stronger than monotone circuit but it's
not as strong as the general boolean
circuit and one can still goof proof
lower bounds on that and thus one can
obtain lower bounds on cutting planes
and there are similar other examples
where you can apply feasible
interpolation to other systems than
resolution by first proving lower bounds
for stronger computational
another thing is and sometimes it
happens that there are proof systems for
which the only interpolation we know of
is via general boolean circuits so it
was like degree D systems or degree two
systems for cutting planes so for
certain systems it's known that you have
an interpolation for boolean by boolean
circuits which is nice but you cannot
prove more about some boolean circuit so
it doesn't give you or Fraga system for
example it's known that Fraga doesn't
even have interpolation by general
boolean circuits ok so even if you prove
modulo some assumptions so even if you
prove lower bounds for general boolean
circuits it will not give you a lower
bounds for frackin and finally this
click versus coloring looks like
something quite artificial because it
requires the variables to be divided
into three parts
XY XZ the tautology is to have special
forms you want the variables X to appear
only positively in one part etcetera but
this is not essential at all you can buy
a little trick you can transform any
tautology whatsoever into a form which
allows you to apply interpolation to it
so for example the bit pigeonhole
principle that I mentioned before one
can prove a lower bound on the bit
pigeonhole principle which doesn't seem
to be of this form at all using
interpolation and that's it except for
open problems
so my first favorite open problem is for
assistant polynomially bounded but some
more exciting question that we might
actually prove is that what happens with
bounded depth Fragger system with parity
gates I told you before that bounded
depth wrecker which is frag of any work
with bounded that formulas I tie has
proved a lower bound and it's a gem but
if you now add parity gates as one of
the connectives and he used them in the
proof we no longer know how to prove
floor wells even though one can approve
circuit lower bounds bounded up circuit
lower bounds with parity gates but
nobody has managed so far to somehow use
the lower bounds in circuit complexity
and to get out of them lower bounds
improve complex so then one open probe
that's like the I guess the most
interesting open problem then the next
one which looks feasible is to extend
the lower bounds for degree two cutting
planes degree two cutting planes are
briefly defined but we know lower bounds
for tree like versions of the system it
will be interesting to extend it to
general dead-like systems and the
problem related to this one is to design
sort of randomized a multi-party version
of feasible interpolation this is
motivated mainly by the analogy between
communication protocols and computations
so in the case of interpol in the case
of resolution it works nicely so the
communication in resolution corresponds
exactly to computations but if you take
more complicated systems and more
complicated communication models there
is no apparent connection between like
some sort of computation and some sort
of communication
thank you
[Applause]
take a couple minutes for extra
questions I won that just maybe call
into question whether open problem two
is actually less exciting than open
problem one the open problem too
actually you know would be the gateway
into proving size lower bound for things
like sum of squares proves which would
actually be very exciting so I think
problem two is more exciting but you
problem one is more has been open longer
but actually I think maybe probably
would be more exciting
so
question of a problem what the usual way
of proving lower bounds for AC that zero
with parity is this method of
approximations etc if you relax a few
system to allow you know low degree
polynomials or some such thing do we
then know that sort of natural
candidates actually start to have short
proves is the candidate for volunteer
the thing that you expected is heart
yeah so a pigeonhole principle thing but
to be is kind of shirt so you you
wouldn't want to have like n plus you
would like the parties to be kind of the
same so I'm so so if I say there is an
by diction between n plus one by us and
this we'll have a short proof because
the parties are different if I allow to
use particle but so if you avoid such
trivial things then pigeonhole principle
from let's say n plus 2 to M
[Music]
we're sending them on three very simple
or you can
when it comes to bomb in-depth Pfleger
it's also open or it has been open if
you just have a very simple system which
is a resolution but instead of having
variables inside the closes you will
have parities so you have sourced some
variables so that's just it's not even
about the depth record it's just the
conjunction disjunction and then
parities so far this is open to proof
overs which is like the simplest thing
that one mine
[Applause]